seven-point game warriors with a lead  thompson just the two points  oh  exploding to the rim  clay thompson powers one down  it's a warrior's turnover  so remember thompson's acl injury was  the left leg the achilles the right  achilles goes off that left leg this  time he's got plenty of explosion here  he certainly does and he knows  against this cleveland cavalier team if  you're going to go to the rim that's the  way you've got to go  strong and steph curry  loves him  the way  the league but especially the warriors  helping cleveland get back in this game  play towson for three there it is  thompson's first made three-pointer